Hi, I'm Glen from the
Android Audio Team.
I focus on performance.
And in audio, that means
one thing, latency.
The time it takes for signal
to pass through a system.
For example, from the
microphone to your app,
to the operating system to
an audio codec and amplifier,
and finally out the speakers.
Basically there's
a delay in how long
it takes sound to
move through your CPU
all the way to your ears.
As the delay gets bigger,
that's where buffering comes in.
But I'm getting ahead of myself.
Let me explain this
using a chicken.
Imagine a chicken wants
to cross the road.
It's an unusual road.
The cars all move
at the same speed
and they're all the
same distance apart.
Maybe they're self-driving cars.
Not too hard for our chicken.
If she makes a run
for it between cars
she'll get across safely.
But there's an obstacle
between the chicken
and the other side of the road.
A fence and a gate.
The colonel manages the gate.
He has nothing against
chickens crossing the road,
but he likes to keep
things neat and orderly.
So the colonel only opens the
gate when he thinks it's time.
He opens the gate right
after a car passes,
so there's plenty of
time for the chicken
to cross the road before
the next car comes.
The colonel works hard.
He cares about his job.
But every once in
awhile the colonel
gets distracted and doesn't
open the gate on time.
And if he's too late,
[TIRES SCREECHING]
[CHICKEN SQUAWKS LOUDLY] uh.
The chicken in this
analogy is the code
that processes audio data,
both in your application
and in the Android
audio framework.
The overall traffic flow
represents the audio hardware,
which consumes data at a
constant rate, no matter what.
Each car is a deadline.
Feed me data now.
In Android, audio samples
are grouped together
into fixed size buffers.
The space between the
cars is the buffer size.
You can think of this buffer
size as either samples or time,
they're equivalent.
Each time a buffer is
completed, the hardware
raises an interrupt
request for a handler
to service the audio hardware.
I ate that buffer
but I'm still hungry.
Feed me more data.
After servicing the
hardware, the handler
wakes up a task to do
the remaining work.
Now audio tasks are among
the highest priority
real time tasks in the system.
So an audio I/O
completion preempts
the current unrelated task, and
we run the audio task instead.
Let's return to our
chicken analogy.
The colonel with a c is
the Linux kernel with a k.
The scheduler decides when
the audio code should run
and the contexts
which makes it so.
And this unfortunate situation?
Well, that's what happens
if our code doesn't
meet the audio
hardware deadline,
just because the
colonel was distracted.
If this were video
or UI code, we'd
say that we just janked
or dropped a frame.
It looks bad, but it's
not a huge problem
if it's only occasional.
But nobody likes it
when you jank audio.
We call it popcorn,
and it sounds awful.
Like this.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
If you're a manufacturer
of an Android device,
and your QA team
hears popcorn, that's
going to be a hard
problem for you to solve.
Remember, audio tasks are
among the highest priority
real time tasks in the system.
So what could possibly go wrong?
Well, there are
many things that can
distract the kernel
with a k from running
our audio tasks on time.
For example, a
random kernel module,
perhaps an unrelated
device driver disables
interrupts or disables
preemption for too long.
Either way this kind
of excessive disabling
will delay the kernel
context switch code
from switching to the
right audio task on time.
We use a tool called
systrace to visualize this.
Here's a real example of
a preemption latency bug.
The audio rights should
be regular like our cars,
but zooming in we see that
one audio write actually
took 130 milliseconds
to complete.
That's a pop for sure.
It's like the colonel
with a c distracted
from opening the gate,
perhaps by a long phone call,
so that chicken didn't
get released on time.
What would you do if
this happened to you?
Well the easiest thing to do
is just bloat up your buffers
like this puffer fish.
Just keep increasing the buffer
sizes until the popcorn stops.
Rather than understanding and
really fixing the root causes,
I have to admit I've done
this once or twice also.
So it's pretty tempting to
do it that way, but so wrong.
Uh-uh.
I'm not going to do
it that way anymore.
My job now is to find all
those places in the kernel
where this happens and fix them.
If you've ever looked
at the Linux kernel,
you know how large
and complicated
a project this might be.
It involves testing
and reviewing
and fixing a lot of code.
Fortunately we're
not doing this alone.
We're working with our
silicon and device partners
to fix such bugs.
This will allow buffer
sizes to be made smaller,
and reduce total audio latency.
Together we've made progress
in reducing latency.
Many audio applications are now
possible that weren't before.
Check out these
resources to learn
how you can take advantage
of the improvements already
available.
Now there's more to latency
than distracted colonels.
Look for other
videos in this series
as we delve into the
root causes of latency,
what we're doing to
reduce it, and how
you can take advantage
of improvements
to write great audio apps.
Thank you for watching.
And remember, don't
distract the colonel.
[SCREAMS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]